Piensen en mi madre por un minuto.
Cuando tenía 15 años, llegué a casa de la escuela un día,
y ella estaba de pie en la larga terraza fuera de la cocina,
con una pila gigante de platos.
Imaginen lo estupefacta que me quedé
cuando empezó a lanzarlos como si fueran discos voladores...
(Risas)
por el aire cálido y húmedo.
Cuando terminó de romper en mil pedazos todos los platos,
volvió para adentro y me dijo alegremente:
“¿Cómo estuvo tu día?”.
( Risas)
Ahora se dan cuenta cómo un niño,
ante un incidente como este,
pensaría que la ira es muda, aislante, destructiva e incluso aterradora.
Especialmente cuando la persona que está enojada es una niña o una mujer.
La pregunta es: ¿por qué?
La ira es una emoción humana; no es ni buena ni mala.
En realidad es una emoción de señal que nos advierte de la humillación,
la amenaza, el insulto y el daño.
Y, sin embargo, en una cultura tras otra,
la ira es una propiedad moral reservada a los niños y los hombres.
Por supuesto que hay diferencias.
En los Estados Unidos, por ejemplo,
un hombre de raza negra enfurecido es visto como un criminal,
pero un hombre blanco enfurecido tiene virtud cívica.
Sin embargo, dondequiera que estemos, la emoción tiene género.
Entonces le enseñamos a los niños a desdeñar la ira en niñas y mujeres,
y nos convertimos en adultos que la penalizan.
¿Y si no lo hiciéramos?
¿Y si no separáramos la ira de la feminidad?
Porque separar la ira de la feminidad significa privar a niñas y mujeres
de la emoción que mejor las protege de la injusticia.
¿Y si, en cambio, pensáramos en desarrollar la competencia emocional
de niños y niñas?
El hecho es que, increíblemente, todavía socializamos a niños y niñas
de maneras muy binarias y opuestas.
Los niños están sujetos a normas de masculinidad absurdas y rígidas.
Se les dice, que renuncien a la emocionalidad femenina
de la tristeza o el miedo,
y que adopten la agresión y la ira como marcadores de la verdadera virilidad.
Por otro lado, las niñas aprenden a ser deferentes,
y la ira es incompatible con la deferencia.
De la misma manera que aprendimos a cruzar las piernas y domar el cabello,
aprendimos a mordernos la lengua y tragarnos el orgullo.
Lo que sucede con demasiada frecuencia es que, para todos nosotros,
la indignidad se vuelve inminente en nuestras nociones de feminidad.
Hay una larga historia personal y política en esa bifurcación.
En la ira, pasamos de ser
princesas mimadas y adolescentes hormonales,
a ser mujeres demandantes y unas pesadas chillonas y feas.
Pero hay para todos los gustos.
¿Eres una latina caliente cuando estás enojada?
¿ O una triste muchacha oriental? ¿Una negra furiosa?
¿O una blanca loca? Pueden elegir.
Pero en realidad, el efecto es que, cuando decimos lo que nos importa,
que es lo que transmite la ira,
lo más probable es que la gente se enoje con nosotras por estar enojadas.
Ya sea en casa, en la escuela, en el trabajo o en la escena política,
la ira confirma la masculinidad y confunde a la feminidad.
O sea que los hombres son recompensados por exhibirla,
y las mujeres son penalizadas por hacer lo mismo.
Esto nos pone en una enorme desventaja, sobre todo a la hora de defendernos
y de defender nuestros propios intereses.
Si estamos frente a un acosador callejero,
un jefe abusador,
o un compañero de clase sexista y racista,
nuestros cerebros dicen a gritos: “¡No puede ser!”.
Y nuestras bocas dicen: “Perdón, ¿cómo?”.
( Risas)
¿Verdad?
Y es contradictorio porque la ira se enreda
con la ansiedad y el miedo y el riesgo y las represalias.
Pregúntenle a las mujeres qué es lo que más temen en respuesta a su ira
y no les dirán “la violencia”.
Les dirán “la burla”.
Piensen en lo que eso significa.
Si tienes múltiples identidades marginadas, no es solo la burla.
Si te defiendes,
si te pones firme, puede haber graves consecuencias.
Reproducimos estos patrones, no de manera grande, audaz y contundente,
sino en la banalidad cotidiana de la vida.
Cuando mi hija estaba en preescolar, cada mañana
construía un castillo muy elaborado, con cintas y bloques, etc.
Y cada mañana, el mismo chico lo derribaba alegremente.
Sus padres estaban allí, pero nunca intervinieron.
No tenían problema en dar las típicas excusas:
“Los chicos son así”,
“Era tan tentador que no pudo evitarlo”.
Hice lo que muchas niñas y mujeres aprenden a hacer:
mantuve la paz de manera preventiva y le enseñé a mi hija a hacer lo mismo.
Usó la palabra.
Trató de bloquearlo suavemente.
Incluso se cambió de lugar,
pero nada funcionó.
O sea que los otros adultos y yo construimos mutuamente
un privilegio masculino en particular.
Él podía correr desenfrenado y controlar el entorno,
mientras que ella callaba sus sentimientos y se acomodaba a las necesidades de él.
Les fallamos a ambos al no darle a su ira la aceptación
y la resolución que merecía.
Ahora bien, eso es un microcosmos de un problema mucho mayor
porque culturalmente, en todo el mundo,
le damos preferencia al desempeño de la masculinidad,
y al poder y al privilegio que vienen con ese desempeño
por sobre los derechos y las necesidades y las palabras de niños y mujeres.
Así que no será ninguna sorpresa, probablemente, para la gente en esta sala
si les digo que las mujeres manifiesten estar más enojadas, por más tiempo
y con más intensidad que los hombres.
Algo de eso se debe a que estamos socializadas para rumiar,
para guardarnos la bronca y reflexionar.
Pero también tenemos que encontrar maneras socialmente aceptables
de expresar la intensidad de la emoción que tenemos
y la conciencia que trae de nuestra precariedad.
Así que hacemos varias cosas.
Si los hombres supieran cuántas veces lloramos simplemente de rabia,
se quedarían pasmados.
(Risas)
Usamos un lenguaje minimizador.
Estamos frustradas: “No, en serio, está bien”.
( Risas)
Nos auto-objetivamos y perdemos la capacidad de reconocer incluso
los cambios fisiológicos que indican ira.
Por lo general, nos enfermamos.
Ahora se sabe que la ira está implicada en toda una serie de enfermedades
que se descartan a la ligera como “enfermedades de la mujer”.
Tasas más altas de dolor crónico, trastornos autoinmunes,
trastornos de la alimentación,
angustia mental, ansiedad, autoagresión, depresión.
La ira afecta el sistema inmunológico, y el sistema cardiovascular.
Algunos estudios incluso indican que afecta las tasas de mortalidad,
particularmente en mujeres negras que padecen cáncer.
Estoy harta y cansada de ver que las mujeres que conozco
están enfermas y cansadas.
Nuestra ira genera malestar,
y el conflicto aparece porque nuestro rol es el de aliviar.
Hay ira que es aceptable.
Podemos estar enojadas cuando ocupamos el lugar que nos corresponde
y apoyamos el orden establecido.
Como madres o como maestras podemos estar furiosas,
pero no podemos enojarnos por los enormes costos de la crianza.
Podemos enojarnos con nuestras madres, como adolescentes, por ejemplo.
Normas y reglamentos patriarcales;
no culpamos al sistema, las culpamos a ellas.
Podemos enojarnos con otras mujeres
porque, ¿a quién no le gusta una buena pelea femenina?
Y podemos enojarnos con hombres de más baja posición social
dentro de una jerarquía expresiva que apoya el racismo o la xenofobia.
Pero tenemos un enorme poder en esto.
Dado que los sentimientos se encuentran dentro del ámbito de nuestra autoridad,
y a la gente le incomoda nuestra ira,
deberíamos estar haciendo que la gente se sienta cómoda
con la incomodidad que sienten
cuando una mujer dice “no” sin pedir disculpas.
Podemos pensar las emociones en términos de competencia y no de género.
Las personas que son capaces de procesar su ira y darle significado
son más creativas, más optimistas,
tienen más intimidad,
resuelven mejor los problemas,
tienen mayor eficacia política.
Como soy una mujer que escribe sobre mujeres y sentimientos,
muy pocos hombres con poder
van a tomar en serio lo que digo, como cuestión de política.
Pensamos en la política y en la ira en términos del desprecio y la furia
que están alimentando un aumento del “macho-fascismo” en el mundo.
Pero si ese es el veneno, también es el antídoto.
Tenemos una ira de esperanza, y la vemos todos los días
en la ira resistente de las mujeres y de las personas marginadas.
Está relacionada con la compasión, la empatía y el amor,
y deberíamos reconocer esa ira también.
El problema es que las sociedades que no respetan la ira de las mujeres,
no respetan a las mujeres.
El verdadero peligro de nuestra ira no es que rompa lazos, o platos.
Es que muestra exactamente hasta qué punto nos tomamos en serio a nosotros mismos,
y esperamos que otras personas nos tomen en serio también.
Cuando eso suceda, es muy probable
que las mujeres puedan sonreír cuando lo deseen.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
(Aplausos) (Ovaciones)